hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one very
interesting sense of justice which
Aristotle talks about in nikka McKean
ethics book 5 is justice as what he
calls complete virtue or as the entirety
the whole of virtue that is something
that encompasses all of the virtues
we're going to see in just a moment that
that doesn't mean that simply having the
virtues automatically means that you're
just because it's all the virtues
exercised in a certain way so he begins
this by carrying out this discussion
that began of legal justice and he
notices that the laws ideally if they're
put together well if they're being run
incorrectly you might say the laws ought
to steer us towards virtue and away from
Vice and and remember that for Aristotle
human beings don't start out virtuous we
may have certain natural virtues but
those are not real virtues yet they're
just sort of the potentiality they're
sort of like going in the right
direction but not really there yet so
there's this this plasticity of human
nature that's there there's this sort of
not blanked how
but we're not yet set as being virtuous
so it's not like we're already virtuous
and the laws just make sure that we stay
that way
the laws actually should actively make
us virtuous and they should also
actively steer us away from Vice
whatever vices we may have happen to
have learned by the time that we become
full
you know subjects of the law so the law
should should tell us to be virtuous and
not to be vicious and how how do they do
that
by forbidding certain actions and by
also commanding other actions one that
aerosol doesn't talk about but I think
he would get behind would be that we
ought to provide for those who have
provided for us in particular for for
parents so you know there wasn't a
social security or welfare network back
in ancient Greece instead what it was as
in most societies is the parents who
took care of the children and who
nourished them sheltered them fed them
clothed them hopefully educated them to
some degree as the parents get old and
the kids are now in their prime the
parents have an expectation to be taken
care of by the the kids in part because
that's the right thing to do and so the
laws would would say punish somebody who
doesn't take care of their parents he
has examples of laws forbidding throwing
away your shield if you're one of the
heavy armed soldiers on the field of
battle
why because throwing away your shield
was a sign of cowardice
that's a vice and not throwing away your
land and actually staying there while
people are trying to stick you with
these long Spears or throwing you know
letting sling stones at you or arrows or
God knows what else
is indicative of courage so it was
supposed to promote courage likewise not
striking people when anger
not sleeping with other people's spouses
that's that's you know sort of a lack of
temperance lack of the control over
one's abilities to withstand the allure
of physical pleasures the law forbids
adultery so the law is is hopefully
steering people towards temperance and
away from from in temperance or in
moderation with respect to sexual
pleasure and you can have laws about all
sorts of things
Aristotle doesn't think for example
about laws pertaining to food and drink
but you know we regulate drink and drugs
things that people take pleasure in and
some places they actually do regulate
food as well you know trying to promote
public health by keeping people from
getting addicted to sugary drinks in
huge quantities so those are those would
be examples so that's the beginning
point of this discussion and Aristotle
thinks that this is steering us towards
this conception of justice which is not
the same thing as legal justice it's not
embodied in a particular law code rather
it's something that the just person the
person who has justice as a quality of
who they are their soul or personality
is able to show in exercise and that
kind of justice will like it says
encompass all of the other virtues
that's quite a lot for Aristotle because
remember we're not only talking about
you know the cardinal virtues justice
prudence temperance courage justice
would of course encompass itself courage
and temperance we've already talked
about but Aristotle talks about a number
of other virtues having to do with many
of which have to do with our
relationships with with our emotions
with goods with other people you know
for example generosity and magnificence
and then the opposed vices to them like
in genus or prodigality with respect to
generosity great-souled Nisour magnum
entity as opposed to vanity or sort of
braggadocio and small sold in this over
here a sort of you know running down of
oneself right ambition good humor proper
control over ones anger all these sorts
of things are cast within the spectrum
of virtues and vices for Aristotle and
so justice encompasses all of them but
he says it doesn't encompass them per se
the way that they are or rather in
relation to other people that's really
an interesting idea
Prost I thought it's Toronado in Greek
and what that means is say for example
temperance temperance means or
moderation means being able to control
one's bodily appetites for Pleasant
things like sleep like drinking alcohol
or their taking you know drugs that have
a fun side effect or eating food or
having sex or laying in the Sun you know
if you're sunbathing and you know it's
it's extremes extreme vice as opposed to
it would be in temperance or a lack of
self-control with respect to those sorts
of things and self-indulgence we could
call it and then in sensibility so you
know how would that be exercised in
relation to another it's easy to see how
it be exercised in relation to one's
self
you know let's think about food well if
you if you're intemperate you know if
you're over on this other extreme you
eat too much you eat the wrong kind of
foods you're unable to control your
appetites you're unable to say no not
only the seconds but the Third's you go
to the buffet and you can't leave a
buffet without being stuffed that can be
bad for oneself
you know you get fat and if you're fat
you're probably not going to be too
happy about some things the lad that the
lack of will control over ones ones
appetites can also be painful to oneself
the person who is intemperate when they
get the normal amount of food a regular
portion size they feel upset about that
whereas the person who's actually
temperate
not only wants to have the right amount
of food but they actually like to have
the right amount of food now how could
that be exercised in relation to others
here's an example I have a family to
feed there's only so much food i gobble
up you know what's there I take seconds
when actually it should be my growing
son or daughter who gets the seconds
because they actually need that amount
of food and I don't I would be doing
injustice to them Aristotle would say
that would be in temperance or a lack of
moderation in relation to another we
could think about the same thing for
global food chains if I know that
purchasing this item here is actually
bad for other people it worsens their
condition I'm participating in something
kind of unsavory pardon the pun by
purchasing it but I say I really like
the taste of that forget I I'm engaging
in a kind of injustice and then by
moderating my my tastes and saying no
you know I'm only going to buy food
products that are not the they're not
encompassing injustice towards other
people in them I would be exercising
temperance in a way that's part of
complete justice likewise if we think
about courage and cowardice or you know
rational going too far being foolhardy
seeing another person being bullied it
doesn't directly concern me it would be
courage for me to step in and say hey
knock it off to put myself at risk for
the good of another person
cowardice would be perhaps joining in on
the bullying saying yeah better them
than me get them or just you know
keeping my head down and not saying
anything not reporting it to anybody
fool Hardiness would be jumping in I'm
gonna get you every single time and
attacking the bully whether it's proven
to do so or not some believes perhaps
it's better to talk to another person
and say hey this this thing and then try
to address it physically yourself
whatever the action will be you may tell
us so you know those are some examples
some of the virtues seem to be more
particularly oriented towards others for
example generosity and it's it's larger
scale virtue of magnificence having to
do with how you spend your money in a
public way but could they have
particularly other oriented
manifestations as well I think that they
could this is something that actually
bears more thinking about but the basic
idea is that when justice is to be
understood as complete virtue as
encompassing all the virtues it's always
in relation to other people now what
Aristotle says that's really interesting
about how this gets exercised how this
gets shown is that it's revealed
particularly by giving somebody
authority or power it's revealed as he
says by rule meaning when somebody
actually gets put in charge because when
you're put in charge you not only manage
your own affairs you manage other people
and you manage other goods that could be
appropriated by you or just you know
doled out to your cronies or could be
used for the common good in a just way
so the virtues and vices would play in
with this if I'm if I'm generous to
really be generous in the workplace does
not mean blowing the budget on pizza
parties every
and you know to boost employee morale
nor does it mean you know trying to work
everybody so that that their bonuses are
going to be good and my bonus will be
stellar you could think for example of
things like scheduling work hours
deciding who gets you know put into you
know development positions and who
doesn't who gets promoted and who was
assigned other other tasks all of that
would fall within what he's talking
about here is complete justice it's also
revealed he says in relation to our
neighbors to those who we we live with
to those who are involved with us say
you know not only in the same
neighborhood but perhaps in the same
school perhaps in the same workplace
maybe if we want to extend this even
further in a sort of postmodern way to
those who are within the same virtual
spaces as us like YouTube Aristotle
talks a little bit about family in this
respect I think that family is where
this is is revealed as well there are
many people who are able to keep it
together with respect to the the outside
world and their relations to that but
they treat their family we could
probably put friends down there as well
they often treat their family in an
unjust way so they may you know they may
look like they have complete justice but
actually you know you scratch the
surface and you find out that they don't
so this is another conception of Justice
this is particularly focused upon the
person who either has injustice has
justice or has injustice as the totality
the the sort of interpenetration of the
virtues oriented towards others